on l'appelait solitude héroïne symbole
de la lutte pour la liberté et la
dignité en 1802 elle s'est jointe en
scène à la résistance quand napoléon
bonaparte a rétabli en guadeloupe l'
esclavage qui avait été abolie après la
révolution française emprisonnée elle a
été exécuté le lendemain de son
accouchement
dernière fois
un extrait de la mulâtresse solitude
roman d'andré schwarz bart qui raconte
l'histoire de cette femme ni d'une
esclave qui avait été violée par un mari
violent durant le long voyage depuis
l'afrique il ya un petit peu le parcours
de toutes ces femmes antillaises qui se
battent en fait pour pouvoir exister
tout simplement la statue de solitude
érigé dans ce jardin qui porte son nom a
été la première à paris une femme noire
aujourd'hui nous faisons plus que
réparer une injustice
nous redonnons une image nous retenons
une silhouette un visage une présence
dans notre vie aux quatre millions
d'êtres humains qui fut réduit en
esclavage
colonie française ils sont plusieurs à
souligner l'importance de commémorer le
passé de nation ni grier de la france
ici en métropole un moment historique
nous avons entendu des paroles terribles
pendant cette campagne électorale ou des
propos de haine une parole que l'on dit
débridée face à l'horreur nous proposons
la beauté du geste la beauté de la rrq
la beauté du combat contre les
injustices et pour les valeurs qui nous
animent il faut absolument faire
comprendre que la splendeur passée de la
france est lié à l esclavage soutient
cet historien il suffit de se promener
dans paris dans dans les ports de
l'atlantique et ses pourboires à quel
point l'argent de l'esclavagé il faut il
faut pas oublier que sous louis xiv en
france l'argent qu'ils venaient de saint
domingue était la principale ressource
du royaume la ville de nantes a été l'un
des grands ports négriers elle accueille
ce mémorial de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé devoir de mémoire dont
l'enseignement oui on a fait des efforts
depuis la loi taubira du nom de
christiane taubira l'ancien ministre de
la justice a été à l'origine de
l'adoption le 10 mai 2001 de la loi
française qui décrète que l'esclavagé
est un crime contre l'humanité cette loi
prévoyait également une plus grande
place à l'esclavagé dans les programmes
scolaires il est toujours difficile
d'enseigner les choses qui ne sont pas
la gloire de la nation enseigner la
guerre d'algérie enseigner vichy
enseigne l esclavage ce n'est pas facile
donc ce qui ce qui est important c'est
de le faire vivre
de fait rentrer les enfants des
centaines d'écoliers venaient de partout
en france en présenter des poèmes et des
chansons esclavage durant cette
cérémonie en après midi en présence du
président français
et pas question pour paris soutient le
conseiller jacques martial de
déboulonner les statues de personnages
esclavagiste edouard glissant deal
oubliettes une offense mais la mémoire
quand les partager à bolillo force alors
nous avons misé sur nos forces
l'esclavagé a été définitivement aboli
en france en 1848 ici annick bureaud
radio-canada paris